in unseren inside seht ihr diese woche
warum sich immer mehr stars ungeschminkt
zeigen so präsentiert sich jennifer
lopez erst kürzlich morgens im
bademantel und ohne make up und die
natürlichkeit steht taylor gut auch ohne
stylistin kann man kaum glauben dass die
sängerin und schauspielerin schon 51
jahre alt ist die kommentare ihrer fans
sind durchweg positiv
ich wünschte mein morning face würde so
aussehen oder so wunderschön sind nur
einige komplimente die sie für das foto
erhält der post hat mittlerweile fast
2,5 millionen likes während sie für
dieses bild auf dem sie perfekt gestylt
ist nur 1,3 millionen likes erhalten hat
lady gaga bekannt für ihre extravaganten
lux hat inzwischen auch kein problem
mehr damit fotos zu posten auf denen sie
ungeschminkt ist die sängerin
präsentiert und letzter zeit immer öfter
ihr ungeschminktes gesicht hatte man
früher das gefühl dass sie sich hinter
einer maske versteckt reichen dem star
is born star heute ein pinker sport bh
und ein wenig sonne völlig aus um sich
wohlzufühlen ab auf events oder im
fernsehen heidi klum sieht immer perfekt
gestylt aus doch ein blick auf ihren
instagram account zeigt dass die
47-jährige privat gerne natürlich ist
und ohne make up genauso schön aussieht
wie auf den roten teppichen dieser welt
das liegt bestimmt auch an ihrem großen
glück tom in denen sie nach wie vor
unsterblich verliebt ist und das auch
gerne ihren fans mitteilt um als
schauspielerin oder musikerin bekannt zu
werden ist gutes aussehen meist nicht
irrelevant das showbiz ist für seine
oberflächlichkeit bekannt 2016
veröffentlichte sängerin alicia keys
einen text im online newsletter lenny
indem sie beschreibt wie sehr sie das
schönheitswahn in den vergangenen jahren
unter druck gesetzt hat sie entschied
sich dazu künftig auf einem make-up
keinen look zu setzen und moderierte
2009 10 sogar die grammys ganz natürlich
alicia keys sei es allerdings auch
wichtig zu betonen dass es jedem selbst
überlassen ist und sie kein problem
damit hat wenn jemand sich schminken
möchte auch im früheren luisa deller die
sich für themen wie politik
nachhaltigkeit und selbstliebe engagiert
zeigt sich auf instagram sehr gerne
ungeschminkt und natürlich in einem
ihrer letzten posting reagiert sie auf
einen
kommentar ob sie nie geschminkt sei
luisa dennert hat dazu folgende meinung
besonders jetzt im sommer kommen sie
noch immer man das thema schminken ja
nein auf und ich finde das muss jedem
menschen selbst überlassen sein ob er
sich schminken möchte oder nicht ich
persönlich finde es sonst im sommer
entspannter sich nicht zu schminken weil
ich ja wenn ich schwitze dann nicht
merke dass mir irgendwas runterläuft
oder verläuft und wenn ich dann abends
ins bett gehe dann brauche ich nicht
irgendwie stunden um mich ab zu
schminken ich finde aber es ist wie
gesagt jedem selbst überlassen ob man
sich schminken möchte oder nicht und da
darf man nicht fair oder auch nicht
dafür beurteilt werden und jungen
menschen würde ich einfach raten da
einfach mal in sich hinein zu fühlen ob
man es gut findet und das mag sich zu
schminken oder auch eben nicht und auf
insgesamt kann man sich ja immer ganz
viel inspiration holen und auch da muss
man glaube ich überlegen er tut mir das
jetzt gut was ich da gerade sehe oder
nicht setzen sich das unter druck wenn
ich in die schule gehe dass ich das
gefühl habe ich muss mich jetzt
schminken weil es alle anderen machen
oder mache ich das weil ich spaß daran
habe und weil ich einfach schön finde
und zum schluss würde ich nochmal sagen
ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtig ist jeder
mensch ist ohne schminke noch viel
toller als mit schminke und ich glaube
das schönste an einem gesicht wenn es um
das thema schminke geht ist das eigene
lächeln
[Musik]